Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and I've just seen around 20 minutes of footage
from Avengers: Infinity War.
I was very lucky to attend a fan event and
also caught some funny moments on camera with
the cast who were attending, and right now
I'm going to give you a spoiler-free reaction
to the incredible footage I saw.
If you're new here and a Marvel fan, feel
free to subscribe as I've got tons of Infinity
War and other MCU videos for you, and there'll
be lots more on the way, including interviews
with the cast.
Plus, I'll be announcing the winner of my
latest Infinity War giveaway later in this
video.
To give you some context: the footage I saw
was from the movie's opening act, though it's
not exactly the beginning of the film.
The clips covered two sequences: one in New
York with Tony Stark, Doctor Strange, Wong,
Bruce Banner, and more, and the other in space
with the Guardians and Thor.
Bits from some of this footage have already
appeared in the trailers, but obviously we
got to see a lot more of what happens, and
judging by that, it looks like quite a few
of my predictions based on the trailers are
on the right path.
As you'd expect from the individual movies
featuring these characters, the tone and look
of each of these scenes is very different.
Which is great as it seems like the Russo
Brothers have managed to retain each character
or group's special sense of identity and brought
that nicely into their own mega-packed movie.
There's a ton of humour in both the New York
and Guardians moments.
In fact, these scenes alone feel like they'll
launch a thousand memes, gifs and quotes.
But, of course, this is just 20-or-so minutes
from the early part of a film that's over
150 minutes long, so I think it's pretty safe
to say that as the stakes rise, the film will
take on a less comic tone.
What's also fantastic about what I've seen
so far is that there's lots of brilliant interplay
between characters who've spent a good deal
of time together and between characters who've
never met before; the action is also pretty
special; the music is on point; there's some
awesome costume reveals; and some cool easter
eggs.
All in all, the footage was a pretty delicious
appetiser for what looks like is going to
be a totally scrumptious main course!
Roll on the end of April!
Now, which characters are you most excited
to see together on screen in Avengers: Infinity
War?
Let me know in the comments and if you've
got any questions, post them below.
I can't give out any spoilers now but I will
be doing my usual breakdowns of the movie
once it's out.
You can also tweet me @Jan_Gilbert or @FlicksCity.
I've got more Infinity War videos on the way
before the film drops, plus some cool footage
of interviews with the cast, so make sure
you ring the bell to get those as soon as
I upload them.
The winner from my Infinity War Q&A giveaway
is on screen now.
If that's you, send me a private message with
your details and I'll get your prize out to
you.
If you liked this video, a thumbs-up is always
appreciated.
And you can also check out more of my Marvel
and other videos by tapping the screen right
here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!